he is the chief medical officer of the
national football league kind enough to
call back in once again uh on to the
rich eisen show prior to an nfl season
taking place in a pandemic he is dr alan
sills how are you dr sills
hey doing great rich how are you i am
doing fine we've got bruce arians coming
on in about an hour's time he announced
yesterday
that the tampa bay buccaneers are a
hundred percent vaccinated do you have a
number do you know how many teams
there are who are 100 vaccinated know
what their vaccination rates are do you
get a report for something like that
doctor yeah we do track that very
carefully rich and right now today
around the league we're at about 93
percent of all players being vaccinated
and that's even after the cut downs
which of course was one of the things we
were tracking is there was some
discussion about you know as teams
reduced their roster that they might
have a smaller percentage but the
percentage of vaccinated players is held
right at 93 percent and of course with
our staff it's virtually 100 that all
our staff are vaccinated so
we're pleased with those numbers
obviously we're going to continue to to
work on them and i'd love to see them
continue to go up but that's where we
are as we approach the start of the
season do you know how many teams are
actually a hundred percent vaccinated
doctor uh i think there are two i would
want to uh just verify that i think
there are two but again that's something
that's changing every single day rich
we're still seeing teams that are having
those conversations having education and
seeing claire step forward so it's a
it's a very dynamic statistic and i feel
like we'll get to some others that do
hit that milestone what do you say what
do you
do to get the seven percent to to to
take the jab here i mean what what
what can you do what is the message
essentially to players who are still
i think it's just like we do with our
patients in the office i mean rich i'm
still a practicing physician and so it's
it's the same approach you have patients
who come in they have questions and you
just need to
walk through their concerns and share
with them the data i'm i'm a big
believer that no one ever gets shouted
into belief about these types of issues
so i think it's about having a measured
conversation and understanding their
hesitancy and trying to address and show
that data and so we as i said uh we
continue to do that at the club level i
think that's also really important to
have a trusted messenger someone who's
who's thought of as reliable and and has
a good grasp of the situation and so
that's going to be different for each
individual in each club but as i said
those conversations are still ongoing
and i participated in a number of them
myself and and again that's not that
different than what we're seeing in the
rest of society this is certainly not
just an nfl issue i was that was my next
question have you personally been
reached out to by a player who is doing
their fact finding we've heard players
say they need more information has a
player picked up the phone or
asked for your number and called you
yes multiple times that's happened
really over the course of the past few
months and
i really enjoy those opportunities
certainly as i said a lot of our team
medical staffs engage in that the nfl
players association and their medical
advisors but but i really um i've
enjoyed those conversations because
again players are just like uh patients
they want information they want to have
their questions addressed and and so
that has been a part of my job over the
past few months dr alan sills nfl's the
nfl's chief medical officer here on the
rich eisen show how has the delta
variant change the protocols and the
approaches that you are attempting to
put into place along with the players
association
well it's definitely changed the game a
bit for us rich in terms of how much
more transmissible and and the fact that
it changes the symptom profile a bit
particularly in vaccinated individuals
so
uh we're really doubling down and
emphasizing the importance of symptom
reporting and i think that's a an
ongoing challenge again not just for the
nfl but the country as a whole you know
people that are vaccinated
uh if they get a little bit of nasal
congestion or sore throat that they
don't always think of it as being
covered because they think wow i'm
vaccinated this must be something else
maybe it's my allergies or i picked up a
cold somewhere so we've seen many of
those cases turn into be coveted
positive cases simply because vaccinated
people have milder disease they don't
have the same disease they had back in
2020 last year with somebody was covet
positive they were unprotected
you saw high fevers and chills and loss
of taste and smell and people that just
really felt terrible for a few days to
even longer
this year again if you're vaccinated it
tends to be much milder illness uh
shorter in duration as well thankfully
and so it is a challenge to get people
to to speak up and say hey yeah i i want
to get tested because you know we do
know that's one of our best methods for
identifying infected individuals if
somebody with symptoms will walk forward
and get tested so we're doubling down on
that and again that's not just a player
issue that's for staff and everyone in
our environment so vaccinated members of
a team staff
players are going to get tested
this fall starting
when like what what what i know that it
was once every two weeks is that going
to be now once every week
because yeah we've changed that cadence
to once per week and we're dividing the
the pool of tested individuals into
three different days so that we're
testing multiple people over over time
kind of getting a snapshot and then
we'll continue on with the daily testing
of unvaccinated people
we also do daily testing of what we call
targeted groups so if someone is exposed
whether they're vaccinated or not if
they have a close exposure a high risk
close contact to a case we will test
them daily as well for for five days uh
and then of course anyone with symptoms
as we mentioned or maybe someone that
shares a household with someone that's
that's currently infected we're going to
be testing them so all told we'll be
testing over a thousand people every day
in the league but it the routine
surveillance testing that you mentioned
for vaccinated individuals that'll be
once per week for each person unless
they'd like to do more they have the
option to request a voluntary test more
frequently or if they have a high
person at home that they're concerned
about they can they can be tested any
time they request so if a player is
vaccinated and is deemed to be a close
contact of somebody on a wednesday
during an nfl week with a game coming on
sunday what happens walk me through what
happens for that vaccinated
player
for that vaccinated player they're going
to continue to come to the facility each
day they'll test on their way in
we will usually put them in a mask for
the following five days whenever they
are inside and again that's if they are
a high risk close contact if we think
they really had a substantial exposure
to someone that's infected
we also do enhance screening with them
so they have a personal interview each
day we go through a list of screening
questions and make sure they haven't
developed any symptoms so there's
additional testing there's masking
inside and there's that screening
process and that continues on for five
days for the testing and masking eight
days for the screening process but
importantly they're still allowed to
come in the team facility participate
with a team play in the game if that's
relevant as long as they they don't have
any signal on any of those items that we
just mentioned now walk me through what
happens with an unvaccinated player that
is deemed to be a close contact on that
wednesday
of a game day week how is it different
yeah if they are high risk close contact
they're essentially under the same
protocols we had last year which 2020
and that's because we saw so many people
who were not protected who had that high
risk exposure and then converted and
became positive on testing so if they're
unvaccinated they're actually out of the
facility for five days they will
continue to test each day
to make sure obviously that we don't
detect any signal but but they're not
allowed into the team environment and
again that's strictly based on what we
saw last year where many of those
individuals eventually turned positive
and if they did it happened within that
five day window of time so a vaccinated
player who's deemed to be a close
contact uh high risk as you mentioned on
a wednesday has a shot to play on sunday
but an unvaccinated player that's it
out
because it's a wednesday and five days
that's right okay so what do you say to
somebody who will then come out and say
that's unfair to the unvaccinated player
what do you say to somebody like that
well again all of our protocols are
based strictly on one guiding principle
rich and that's trying to keep the team
environment as safe as we possibly can
uh you know last year and also this year
we said they're going to be positive
cases again whether they're among
vaccinated or unvaccinated people as
long as this disease is endemic out of
society we're going to see some positive
cases what we're trying to do is
identify them keep them isolated and
mitigate the risk to everybody else in
the building so all of our protocols are
strictly built around the idea of what
works to keep the team safe how do we
keep the team safe and certainly what we
learned last year through our data was
if you're unvaccinated and you have one
of these high-risk exposures again we're
not just talking about passing someone
in the hallway we're talking about a
substantial amount of time you spent
within a very defined distance with with
a positive individual your risk of
converting and becoming positive is is
significant and because of that we don't
want that person walking around in the
building and potentially spreading this
to others so
again our protocols are not about
punishment or distinguishing people you
know based on choices is strictly what
can we do to keep it as safe as we can
for everybody involved science facts
basically is what you're saying exactly
right yeah we've taken the data we've
tried to let the data lead us
and the reality rich is i mean the part
that i didn't say is
if you're unvaccinated you are at a
higher risk if you are unvaccinated and
you are getting exposed particularly to
delta in a close manner you have a
really high risk of catching it it's
just very transmissible so we're just
trying to protect everyone including the
person who's exposed but also obviously
as i said the larger team environment
and then dr alan stills nfl chief
medical officer you are a neurosurgeon
as you said you are a practicing doctor
as well as you know just happened to be
the chief medical officer of the
national football league in 2021
so what i i'd like to utilize this time
if you don't mind to
address some of the responses i've
gotten
when i have tweeted about instagram
about discussed on the show about my
experience of being a breakthrough
infection back in july
and my desire to get everyone as
vaccinated as possible so there are no
more variants to pierce my vaccine or
heaven forbid what i you read about
might be coming out of the southern
hemisphere a vaccine resistance strain
which is freaking me out to be very
honest with you
so what do you say to somebody who say
masks don't
work dr sells
well
again you mentioned rich i'm a surgeon
uh i've spent my life wearing a mask in
the operating room and we do that for
one simple reason because they do work
they reduce the risk of passing uh germs
and infection to patients that we're
operating on so i i think it's very
clear that masks are effective in
reducing many respiratory diseases i
mean we've we've done the same thing for
years with tuberculosis and influenza
and a host of other diseases
i think what's challenging of course is
mass work when they're worn properly
when they fit well and and when they're
more in the right environment and that's
always a challenge when you start
applying that broadly but but again
i don't think anyone wants to go in and
have a surgery done by someone who's not
wearing a mask i think
that's probably what would feel very odd
and is a risk that most people don't
want to take
um so so i think it's really again about
what are the best mitigation measures
for each situation
and how we can we protect ourselves but
beyond the mass risk what i would say to
patients are
the the most effective tool we have
right now are these vaccines most
effective tool to keep us safe and again
keeping us safe means preventing serious
illness hospitalization and death that's
what the vaccines were designed to do
and by the way that's what they're doing
i mean they have a remarkable
effectiveness in preventing serious
illness and death we spoke a couple of
minutes ago that if you're vaccinated
and you do test positive it tends to be
a very mild illness that's somewhat
short-lived that's very different than
what we see in unvaccinated individuals
and so i i think the data is very clear
there and the last thing i would tell
you rich is is again something you could
uh talk to any um critical care doctor
or nurse uh you just go to our hospitals
nowaday um when you're in our hospitals
the people who are
most ill who are in the intensive care
unit and and who are
struggling with severe illness are
overwhelmingly unvaccinated and so i
think the data is very clear that these
vaccines are doing what they were
designed to do which is preventing
serious illness hospitalization and
death last time i had you on before last
season dr sills i was asking you all
about the vaccines that i was hoping
would be coming and you know as we all
know they arrived with emergency
uh usage uh approval from the fda in
december and then we all know what's
happened in 2021 what are you hearing
about other variants are you hearing
anything about that about that that
could clearly change the game for
protocols in the middle of a season
what are you hearing about
what i just mentioned you read about
vaccine resistant variants what what's
on your radar screen on that front well
once again we just go back to sort of
our basic virology and other infectious
diseases rich and that's the nature of
viral illnesses that they will mutate
and other strains will arrive i mean
again that's why we have
different flu shots every year because
different strains of the flu arise so
that's really not unique to covet 19 and
so
i i think there will be other variants
it will it will develop over time
particularly as we have large areas of
the world that are unvaccinated and
unprotected and the virus has a chance
to mutate but i just go back to saying
that the data so for so far shows that
the vaccines we have are still
remarkably effective against all these
variants even delta which is so much
more transmissible um the the vaccine is
doing a great job again preventing
serious illness hospitalization and
death so i have a lot of confidence in
the vaccines
as we've said for a league we're always
going to have to be flexible and
adaptable we're going to look at the
data and see where it takes us as far as
our protocols and and they likely will
change i mean as you know last year they
changed throughout the season they
probably will again this year but we'll
do that based on what our data is
telling us what the science is leading
us to
and doing what's safest for our entire
team environment dr sills i appreciate
the time thanks so much best of luck
let's uh is that i i always ask um folks
in the nfl if they've got a a target
they got something that they put on the
on the grease board last year a .08 if
i'm not mistaken
positivity rate despite no vaccines is
that that's you want to beat that right
that's what that's what you're looking
for in 2012 well i think just to to not
get too far in the weeds rich positivity
rate probably the wrong measure this
year we're looking for incidence rates
because we want to just see how many
people you know potentially um you know
can be affected but more importantly we
want to avoid that serious illness
hospitalization death keep keep our
players coaches and staff safe and their
families and be able to get through our
season and i'm very optimistic about
that i think i've said publicly before i
think if our entire country was as
vaccinated as the nfl is we'd be in a
far far different place with this
pandemic so i hope that we can lead the
way once again and show the benefits of
vaccination and our ability to pursue
some of the things we enjoy in life and
go forward at the same time thanks for
the time dr alan sills appreciate it
thank you have a great day that's dr
alan sills nfl chief medical officer
here on the rich eisen show hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here